bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans science
clic la lumière dans tout l'univers
s'étend un champ électromagnétique
lorsque ce champ est perturbé tout comme
la surface d'un lac qui se déforment
lorsqu'on y jette une pierre une onde se
propage dans le vide à partir de la
perturbation
c'est une onde électromagnétique
l'émission d'une onde électromagnétique
produit des sortes de vagues à
intervalles réguliers on appelle
longueur d'onde la distance entre deux
vagues plus la longueur d'onde est
grande plus les vagues sont étirées et
plus sa longueur d'onde est petit plus
les vagues sont rapprochées entre elles
nos yeux sont capables de détecter les
ondes électromagnétiques dont la
longueur d'onde est comprise entre 400
et 800 nanomètres
ce sont ces zones là que nos yeux
peuvent capter que l'on appelle lumière
en adoptant différentes longueurs d'onde
la lumière peut apparaître sous
différentes couleurs plus la longueur
d'ondés grande juste à lumière va tendre
vers le rouge les plus la longueur
d'ondés petit plus la lumière va tendre
vers le violet entre le rouge et le
violet la lumière adoptent
successivement toutes les couleurs de
l'arc-en-ciel orange jaune vert bleu et
indigo
c'est en mélangeant toutes ses couleurs
que l'on obtient de la lumière blanche
tous les objets émettent des ondes
électromagnétiques les longueurs d'onde
émise par un objet dépendent en partie
de sa température plus un objet est
chaud juste et longueur d'onde qu'il
aimait son petit
par exemple un être vivant dont la
température n'est pas très élevé émet
des ondes électromagnétiques infrarouge
de grandes longueurs d'onde
les infrarouges ne sont pas visibles
pour les humains mais certaines caméras
à vision nocturne les captent pour voir
dans le noir
maintenant lorsqu'un objet est assez
chaud certaines des longueurs d'onde
qu'il aimait deviennent visibles
on peut alors voir cet objet show
rayonner selon la couleur correspondante
c'est pour cela qu'en chauffants un
objet comme par exemple du métal pour le
voit rouge puis jaune et si l'objet est
extrêmement chaud comme certaines
étoiles il apparaît bleus
la lumière se comporte donc comme une
onde nom peut également la représenter
dans certaines situations comme un flux
de particules des photons un objet qui
émet de la lumière produit des photos
tout comme l'ondé électromagnétique le
photon à une certaine énergie qui
correspond à l inverse de sa longueur
d'onde
ainsi plus un photon possède d'énergie
plus sa longueur d'onde est petit
de ce fait les photons que l'on voie
bleue avec une petite longueur d'onde
possède plus d'énergie que ce que l'on
voit rouge la couleur d'un photon dépend
donc de son énergie
les atomes qui sont à la base de la
matière peuvent adopter différents
niveaux d'énergie
lorsqu'un faute on arrive sur un atom si
son énergie permet à cet atome de monter
à un niveau supérieur
l'atom va absorber le photon et c'est
l'énergie absorbée qui va lui permettre
de changer de niveau
ainsi en fonction du type d'atomes
certains photons sont absorbés et
d'autres non car leur énergie ne permet
pas à l'atome de changer de niveau c'est
pour cela que la couleur d'un objet
dépend des atomes dont il est fait par
exemple les atomes d'une carotte absorbe
en majorité les photons bleus la lumière
blanche qui éclaire la carotte qui est
composé de toutes les couleurs va se
réfléchir la composante bleue de cette
lumière va être absorbée et ainsi notre
oeil va percevoir le mélange de toutes
les couleurs sauf le bleu c'est à dire
de l'oranje en plus d'absorber des
photons les atomes peuvent également
ceux des excités c'est à dire descendre
dans les niveaux d'énergie en ceux des
excitants l'atome perd une partie de son
énergie qui est transformé en un photon
la plupart des objets émettent de telles
fautes on avec trop peu d'énergie pour
qu'ils soient visibles mais si l'énergie
est suffisante
ces photons émis deviennent visibles et
l'objet aimé de la lumière c'est comme
cela qu'une flamme est clair une pièce
sa chaleur se transforme en lumière
après avoir absorbé un premiers photons
certains atomes ont la capacité
d'émettre subitement à second photons
avec assez d'énergie pour que ce second
photons soit visible ces atomes
produisent donc une lumière d'une
certaine couleur en absorbant une autre
couleur c'est par exemple de cette façon
que brillent les protéines fluorescentes
de certaines méduses enfin qu'on la
considère comme une onde ou comme des
photons la lumière se déplace toujours
pour tout le monde à la même vitesse la
vitesse de la lumière est une constante
très importante car ne change jamais et
ne peut être dépassé par aucun objet qui
possède une masse car pour ce faire il
faudrait une énergie infinie
cependant même si les fautes on se
déplace toujours à la même vitesse
la lumière peut être ralentie dans un
milieu matériel comme dans l'eau en
effet en se déplaçant les fautes on se
heurte aux atomes de l'eau et avançant
higgs hague
ce chemin en zigzag plus long qu'en
ligne droite prend plus de temps à
parcourir et donc le faisceau lumineux
et ralenti c'est de là que vient la
réfraction qui fait que l'on voit un
objet d'efforts mais lorsqu on le plonge
dans l'eau ce phénomène de
ralentissement de la lumière peut
devenir très important c'est par exemple
le cas des photons émis au coeur du
soleil qui étant très ralentie par les
différentes couches de l'étoile peuvent
mettre plusieurs dizaines de milliers
d'années avant de sortir du soleil alors
qu'en ligne droite ce chemin de leur
prendre et que deux secondes